tonight vaccines are top of mind for
many nevadans specifically concerns over
second shot side effects yeah we've
heard your concerns your stories and we
went straight to the source to get some
answers on what you can expect when it's
your turn
sasha loftis joining us now live outside
the convention center with more sasha
denise and bryan the covet 19 vaccines
on the market right now
are some of the safest we've ever seen
but many people have been reporting
side effects especially after that
second shot
it may seem scary but medical experts
say it's not necessarily
a bad thing ginger allen is
officially immunized against covid19
happy to say i almost had no side
effects i had a little bit of a headache
and took some tylenol she was nervous
leading up to her second
shot but says the peace of mind and
protection
made it all worth it not only is it a
safe vaccine but it's also a very very
effective vaccine
unlv school of medicine dean mark j khan
says
she's one of many who shared concerns
over vaccine side effects
so it's important to know why they're
happening both brands out now
use mrna technology to help our bodies
respond to the virus
the first shot acts as a primer the
second is a boost
and that can lead to more reported
reactions
because of that boosted immune response
we have more symptoms
and the symptoms are really referable or
due to an intact immune system so in
many ways the side effects tell us that
our immune system is working
as for alan she believes the reward
outweighs the risk
i feel very confident in science and our
medical community she hopes others will
consider what she calls
a necessary step to bring back a new
sense of normal science works
now dr khan says though that side effect
is a sign of an immune response to the
vaccine if you don't have any side
effects
that doesn't mean it's not working he
said it's important to remember that
everyone's body reacts differently
and both moderna and pfizer the vaccines
on the market right now
are both extremely effective yeah some
people say they just have like a little
pinch in the arm others you know are
different
so sasha ask for the vaccines they're
soon going to be the third one we've
been telling you about that
the u.s panel has endorsed johnson and
johnson's one dose vaccine
did dr khan also talk about that with
you tonight
denise he did speak a lot about it he
said the entire medical community is
really excited for this vaccine he says
because it is one dose
it's a lot easier to distribute to the
community and he said it doesn't require
that extra
deep freeze temperature like moderna and
pfizer do so it's easier to store
he said though it is important to
remember that if you are offered a
vaccine if you get an opportunity for an
employee of an appointment
it's important to get whichever one is
offered whether that be mederna
pfizer or johnson and johnson reporting
live tonight sasha loftis
8 news now all right sasha thanks for
that tonight